I see you!! Oh, I see you over there~
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Subnautica. I just
tested the limits of my oxygen
capability because I swam from my base
to the surface and it is just barely
there but now I'm gonna go back I
need to make... uh.. I need to get the materials
for a bioreactor...um, and I need to get
materials for various other things.
I want to get enough to make another room
so I can get two bioreactors but one of
the things that I discovered- * gets cut off by loud groaning noise* eeeh...god that's- ohhhh what the
FUCK was THAT? WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?! OH
MY GOD! You silly playful bitch you
scared me!
yeeesh aye yee ayeaye I don't like that
thank you. I don't like the idea of you
playing like whales just breaching out
through the water. Oh so majestically ah fuck you.
Welcome back I'm headed back to my life
pod I will be skipping ahead in just a bit.. uh.. to
get the materials, get my Seamoth and
then get back uh but before that I need to get
materials I need to make a second base
but one of the things that I discovered
is that lantern fruit are an amazing
source of energy in a bioreactor so what
I need to do is I need enough titanium
to take with me over there so that I can
make two bioreactors and then make the
grow beds to be able to make a lot of
lantern fruit. So I got a long way to go but I
just want to pop in to say hello so laddiedaaa
Oh I'm an idiot! I have this thing! Oh
I'm- just- fucking- are you kidding me
god dammit I'm such a fuckin doof... FUCK!
*High pitched voice* Woo hoo woopy doopy, here we go
fuck them fuck that fuck you and fuck
all y'all I'm getting you. No I know I know
I know I forgot how hard life was
without this stupid mobility. Scary life it
was. Oh no we've got a message
oh no oh no
"Aurora, its Sunbeam. We made orbit, scans have found
a landing site on the planet that's only
rated hazardous. It's our best shot.
We've sent you the coordinates. We'll be
there in two days time.
Cross your fingers the weather holds, and
don't leave us waiting. Sunbeam out."
Well that's not good I am not prepared
for that I can't turn off although
people have said that I can't turn off
the uh- oh boy ya that's going to be bad it's
gotta gun on it it's gotta big dangerous
guuun! You're gonna die. So there's no way
to turn off the gun right now but that
may change in the future but I think
they're gonna die I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure they're gonna die. But we've
got better things to do with our life we
gotta go get our Seamoth back,
we gotta get bubble butt, we gotta get
enough materials and then we all get the fudge out of
here
yuup! Oh and I forgot that Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise,
and Marshall are  over here but I'll get them
later time to worry about that now
ok so as I'm gathering materials I've
got some more people's names to read so
thank you for commenting down below
[salad exist one] says there are FOUR
leviathans in Subnautica and not three in case
you didn't know. And I'm doubting this a
little bit but they say there's Reaper
Leviathan, Sea dragon, Sea Emperor but
then they also say there's a Ghost
Leviathan!?
And I'm not sure how much I believe that
I think that might be something that you
made up but I have no way to prove it
otherwise so I appreciate the uh... the the the
daring that you have.
Next up is [phantom 17] just some
random facts about the Warper
The Warper is actually a cyborg
created by the ancient aliens and it's
robot half itself is what makes it able
to teleport so that's that's fascinating
the the aliens made the Warper and
I believe, I believe I read that somewhere
as well and I just I don't think I've
ever talked about it's really
interesting to see that the ancient
aliens built the Warper and I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure that the the
purpose of the Warper was to corral and
collect all of the infected creatures
and bring them to a controlled
environment or possibly kill them now I
don't know which is which but I know it
probably isn't good news for anybody
involved
next up is [christian four and three] who
said make plasma gun with knife to kill
Reaper Leviathan and I don't know that
just means I want to get a plasma gun
and then attach a knife to it and it
shoots a plasma infused knife at a
Reaper Leviathan and it kills it
that sounds awesome I want that I think
they may be mixing up dead space with
this game but I'll forgive them for now
because that's just damn cool and we have
[God's 17 rag on 18] who said Mark you
need to delete the files named cells
cache and compiled octrees cache in your
save files this will make the game go
smoother. Now I have not done this number
one: because I'm hesitant to go deleting
files in my save game file but if it can
make it a little smoother I might be
interested in doing that but I don't
know if that's just to work around if
that's actually something that's gonna
help me in the long run but
we'll see I just don't know ok so that's
all the names that I got thank you
everybody for commenting and now I've
got the lubricant I've got my Seamoth
now all I have to do is get as much
titanium as possible before I get out
there
the only problem is I only have 18 slots
for titanium and I think that's gonna be
enough because if I build another basic
chamber I would have probably have
enough to make two bioreactors and then
I should have enough extra titanium to
build whatever I do need maybe some more
solar panels just to bank more power
even though they're not going to be
making any power they do add power bank
so that if the bio actors are constantly
going that maybe it's gonna keep me
powered. But again I won't have the fuel
for that until I get enough bio
creatures which just means I'm going to
become an eco-terrorist even more than I
already am and to start nabbing fish
out of the sea and feeding into the
horror that is my bioreactor also I have
to be over by the island in 30 minutes
to watch the Sunbeam explode
ok so we've got just about as much
titanium as we can hold I picked up one
piece of silver because I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna need maybe two pieces but I
know I can get silver down there so I'm
not particularly worried about that but
we've got all the materials that we need
I'm pretty sure and we've got a beacon
to guide us down into the briny depths
of Hell where I know my base shouldn't
be but it is anyway because I'm an idiot
and we've got three diamond which means
that I'm going to be able to make that
drill arm wait,  am I? I'm checking my math
here
NO I am not cuz I don't have a
fucking plasteel ingot. WELL shitty tits
oh well that's a problem for another
fucking day
fuck but alas I shall not get mad about
that is not a big deal because now I
have everything that I need to be able
to go down there and then upgrade all of
my capabilities except for the fuckin drill arm to
be able to get more stuff out of the
digging holes but that's ok again
because I have confidence in what I'm going
to be doing down there. So I'm gonna go ahead
and get to the build phase and then
whatever it's about five minutes left on
the Sunbeam I'll probably take the old
Seamoth out and witness the fireworks the
Sunbeam exploding in a fiery hell hole
which should be fun you know frankly I
I'm okay with that I'm gonna get a bowl
of popcorn and Imma set atop the
mountain and just watch it blow... it's still
pretty it's still terrifying off there
goes the music and now it's terrifying
it was more pretty and now it's more
terrifying
ok so what I'm gonna do first is I'm
gonna focus I'm gonna focus on the
bioreactor, the first bioreactor because I
should have everything that I need to
build one. (Warning: Emergency power only.-
Oxygen production offline.)I know, I know, I know. *wail-like mating call??* Wait, you should be rotated.
*Wild animal sound of completion* Habooski
ok so now "A reliable power source is a
crucial step towards self-sufficiency.
If you are not already, consider keeping a
photo journal of your achievements to
remind you of how far you've come since
washing up here."
I wish you took automatic pictures
because that'd be kinda cool but I don't
have time to worry about it, I'm actually
recording everything so it's not a big deal
Now I need to build another base extension
I should have planned this better
I should have planned this much better
because I didn't- I didn't put a lot of room to be able to do this
oh well! whatever
who cares if it's gonna be halfway in
the mountain side- it'll move for me I
think yea it'll- it'll move, it'll move for me
...right
yeah it moved yea it moved for me yeah okay
I get it all right okay so there was
some fishies- sorry! you're gonna be
subjected to a horrible fate and then tossed
into a meat grinder and turned into electricity
don't ask me how! I don't understand the
technology with which I am building
All I know is that you need to be sent-
Oh you're pretty one
Woah I got an Eyeye! I don't know what an Eyeye is
I didn't even know the Eyeye existed!
I've never seen the Eyeye before in my life!
welp time to toss them in the meat grinder!
oh well! Wonderful new things and now its dead.
"Evolved the see predators before they see it."
Well it didn't see ME coming! so too bad for it
Alright let's see this
All right what can we put in here?
No I did not mean to eat that!
Okay that Eyeye is eat!
YAY! I've got power! (Karen talking in the background) yay ok so that- that
gets power very very VERY slowly and I'm
beginning to think the- the solar
panels are actually doing absolutely
dick diddly. Oh! Look! I've got some
mountain in my room that's ok but since
I'm able to build two and constantly
fuel them with a steady supply of
lantern trees I should have everything
that I need to be able to build exactly
what I need.
So! with that being said I'm going to
make this the grow area because it seems to
already be halfway blasted out so I'm
only gonna need one for now so I'mma  build one
eh I'll build it in the back. I want to build this one for now
habitty be po po po po! Feels like home and
I'm gonna put- I'm not going to eat you
switch there we go
ok so THAT'S gonna grow up all big and strong
ah it's getting there! it's a little oh-
Look at the Little Billy! I see him
growing already! What a lovely little guy.
ok so that's going- I've got one which is
not a lot of power but enough and then
I'm gonna get another one and FINALLY I'll be able to
dock my frickin Seamoth and my frikin other thing in here
oh! it seems brighter already
oh is it daylight? Or is this just because my base is
powered? That's awesome!
When it has power it gets light? Oh that's so nice!
It is so much brighter!
Is it just like fate shining on me?
Sorry Eyeye, you gotta go.
*sigh* It's so nice- Oh you're quick oh you're quick ain't ya
Oh you're quick
Oh you're not that quick haha
Not that quick! Nya ha ha! I feel bad.
*mumbles* I don't really feel bad at all.
Alllright doo ba doop boop~
Boopadoobeedoop boop boop boo~
I do think- I do think it's-
I do think it's brighter down here! Like I don't
know if I'm just feeling peppy because
things are going my way (finally) but
you know, it's a little brighter! Little brighter! You know?
Hey you know what else is cool? I'm gonna be able to make a
water filtration machine, which is a
really really ridiculously cheap machine
to make like, constant supply of water-
water filtration- it only requires two titanium.
Which I don't have!
I gotta go BACK and get it!
But by the time I come back here, I should have
absolutely everything I need and I
should have lots of power and everything
should be cool and hunky dory,
so I'm gonna go on one more titanium run!
I'mma come back here and by the time
I come back here it's gonna be plenty of power!
It's freaking bright as fuck here- you
know what- I'm gonna dock- I'm gonna dock-
I'M GONNA DOCK- I shouldn't say that over
and over again but I'm gonna dock
My (unintengible) right in here!
woo- Right in ohhhhhhhhhh
Ohhh thrust butthole!
YES! Oh fuuuuuuuuuuuuck
*Emergency power only- Power Restored* mmm  I forgot that that
was gonna charge that thing,
WELL I bet it's dark out here now! oh nope still
a little bright. Okay! Well- it's hanging
halfway with its ass out
oh that's adorable- oh it's farting up a storm!
Oh how about that- ok I'll come back when
things aren't so terrible. Alright so now I just
gotta go get some um- titanium I think I'm
pretty sure I still have time to go get
titanium and then come back before the
Sunbeam explodes. So I can make some even
MORE IMPROVEMENTS to my base before everything goes to shit.
*Something hits the Seamoth* Owww come on- stahp it!
Oh my base is nnnot happy. I'm getting like
spam- STOP IT!- I'm getting like spam
messages over and over again about how
my base is terrible.
Also I'm gonna go out and get the
necessary materials for plasteel, which
is not a lot- I think it's just lithium and um-
titanium ingots. So I should be able to
do that one-two punch get in get out be done.
OKAY alright we got oodles and oodles of
titanium now and we've got one titanium
ingot and I just need to swing by the
purple mushroom area and grab a lithium
because I'm pretty sure they're down
there and if I'm not mistaken there's an
entrance to the purple mushroom area
rrright down here in this hell hole right here.
mmyep I was right! I know this place way
too much. Which I probably shouldn't
because it's super scary and I hate
going down in this one- eugh. It's just always
so disconcerting the way it bobs you
back and forth and the way they're worms
inside the mushrooms
It's not okay man! It's super weird but
I'm pretty sure there's lithium there. Unless I'm
horribly mistaken and incredibly stupid
where the hecky heck was lithaaaum- heey lithium I knew it!
I knew it! Is there anyone that's not near a freaking shark-
yes! yes! okay! all right! good! grab theaaas (this)
(unintelligible)
grab THIS- well-
boop!
ok. SO I don't think I need more than two-
I think plasteel is just literally one
but just to be sure
ah fuck- fucking- doodooloodoo doo doo
what've we got (x2) what've we gooooat
What was I doing? Plasteel ingot? There we go-
Habooshki! Yeah i only needed one lithium but I'll hold onto the lithium just in case.
SO I HAVE a whole bunch of shit. I've got a- bluauegh
I've got- Woah why is it all- bleughh (blue)
WHY IS IT BLUE and blocked out- I don't know but
I got a bunch of- ah- got a bunch of
titanium I got plasteel ingot I got three
diamond I've got an extra lithium
extra silver and I've got these ion
crystals, that I don't know what they do
but apparently they're gonna explode.
ok so now we got 10 minutes- aauhh- I'll be
cutting it really close but I think I
can do it! I think I can do it! I saved, but
I think I can do it! I think I can gun it
all the way over to my base, build the
stuff, do the things, then gun it all
the way back, keep no time wasted be
super productive this whole time and be
super awesome and cool!
OTHERWISE everything is gonna go to
shit and I'm not going to be able to get anything done, which is also an option
(fake laughter) hahahahaha
(cry-laughter)
UGH I haven't even made the modification station have I?
NO I HAVE NOT! I'm not gonna be able to build it anyway!
Why the FUCK- FUCKING God dammit!
I'm such an ass. >:(
oh NO!!! oh GWUOH! (NO)
oh- wait there's power
What? There's POWER, it's just the warnings that are bullshit!
OH oh that's GREAT! oh that's good
oh (chuckles) that's good. ok what do I need to do
to build a goddamn modification station
that's what I want to know right now
computer chips OH well I can't make that oh fuck
well this still has Spadefish and that's
still working so these are still
technically working which is good
it's working very slowly and ah man I
need- oh I need one more silver don't I?
I don't have that, no- yeah I need one more
silver and the table coral sample which
I think I can get here, I'm pretty sure
ah fuck I need to be able to drop my
stuff off, which means that I need to be able
to make a locker and let's do it in here I like it here anyway the walls are
pretty barren okay baboo da boo pa doo~ you know what?
this locker's better I won't be able to
put a name on it but it's bigger
shuuuu booski this is temporary don't anybody
get upset about this I just need to
store things for temporaries while I go
hunt for what I need which is very important.
okay! alright so if I just go hunt I know
for a fact that you can get silver out
of the deposits around here
but I'm gonna be close on time because I
gotta get over there in the next minute
I can just find
fucking ahh forgot ahh fuck I need to repair
this thing god damn it i'm such an asshole
all right
ah ba ba alright let's just let's just
do it before I blow it up somehow
'cause I'm gonna blow this thing up I know-
AHHH and fuck I'm out of time god
dammit AHH all right I'm going back I
gotta go back I'm not gonna try to cut
it short I'm gonna go back now I'm not
gonna risk it and then I'll get silver
and will bring that back table coral fucks
it's so hard when you're not cheating
but I'm not gonna cheat ever so I'm not
doing that
that's why I have to deal with this is
this is what real life and fate life game is
like gotta work for what you want you
gotta work hard and get what you want so
you can get what you need
so let's go watch the Sunbeam blow up
and people get killed
that's a horrible thing to say okay I
could probably cut it close
I probably could have gone and made the
stuff that i need made the computer
chips and then made the modification
station then all ass over here that probably
would have been perfectly acceptable but
for now we are here and um- yeah I don't
feel like it's going to be good I feel
like it's going to be a bad thing,
should I write SOS in the sand and just- no.
Try to hope for the best here
Maybe they'll MISS may-maybe it'll
miss maybe it's gonna miss maybe it'll miss
you know? that's and option big baby
I think- I literally think- I think-
I'm pretty sure that the marker here is
literally telling you to stand here
because it's the best view to (chuckles) watch it
explode and to watch the gun fire, which
I've been looking forward to- I have not
seen this gunfire and I've been tempted
because I've seen videos and stuff that say like "The precursors are gone firing!"
but this is the rrrreal deal.
And I just wish that target reticle would go away.
oh- oh OH OH OH OH oh oh OH oh god
HOW? oh oh!
uh- look out??? oh-
oh no (x3)
*gun makes whale-like noises while mark makes a weird face*
Mark: huh, ok?
D:
I think that might be the warning! oh boy.
(PDA/Karen: Attention - patching in a local broadcast from the Sunbeam.)
(I don't believe it, there's someone down there!)
Mark: Yeah? (Aurora survivor we have your PDA
signature.) Mark: *Sees Sunbeam* Oh, hi... (I don't know how you walked
away from that wreck, let alone survived since then,
but we'll be happy to bring you onboard and hightail back to federation space.) Mark: Oh no.
(Stand back, we're approaching the landing site now.
Breaking atmosphere in 5... 4... 3...)
*Static*
(What is that? No the RED spike.)
*Static* *Cannon charging*
Mark: Oh boy (x2) OH BOY. (Quinn: From this planet?!) (Cannon computer: Weapons firing.)
Mark: OH BOY
*Cannon beam*
*Sunbeam explodes*
*thundering echo*
*Wind*
Mark: Weeeellp
Dat's not good...
D'aww, that sucks
Buuuh that's no good
I wonder if there's any salvage *Giggles* I can
recover. I doubt it! Oh, man, *laughs* and
now the guns just in firing position
oh geez... well- oh hello friend! did you see that?
"Yeah, it was fucking awesome!"
Well that's-that's mean someone got shot :(
So anyway that is all the time that I have
for this episode of Subnautica, uh, ended
on a high and a low note but alas we are
stuck here on this planet until we solve
the problem and maybe forever
this might be our home here, alone, lost,
scared and afraid
But hey! that's half the fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video BUH-BYE!
*outro music plays*